these people come here every month
demanding Justice Juan Carlos Cruz was
murdered with a shot in the head 3
months ago in an attempted robbery he
was a doctor and was killed in the
province of Buenos ciris where violent
crime has been on the
rise they shot him in the head when they
tried to Rob his car and he didn't do
anything they just shot him and we don't
know why what hurts is what is happening
my uncle wanted to save lives and those
who killed him did not care there are
reports of violence incidents every day
as people prepare to vote for the next
president on Sunday the rise in violent
crimes in woses have alerted authorities
about the social tension that exists in
part of the country with poverty rates
on the rise and with families struggling
to make hands meet because of soaring
inflation farri candidate Javier M
promises to battle insecurity with more
forces on the streets and harsher laws
to punish crime economy Minister Serio
Masa pledges to create a national law
enforcement agency like the FBI to
combat crime and drug trafficking father
Andre toini works in the parish in VI
soldati where crime has become an
everyday issue he says a comprehensive
plan is needed to contain the ongoing
situation we used to have more police
there is economic need this increased
violence young people that do not go to
school drugs in our neighborhoods it's
more complicated and this generates
delinquency this doesn't mean that
honest people go out to steal but lack
of resources makes everything more
difficult that's why most argentines are
desperate for solutions that will
protect them and their loved ones from
random and often violent
crime
Alis make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer